and if I think I don't change I don't
keep up with the times
well I'm outdated if you're not updated
you are outdated when you sweat a lot in
times of peace you bleed less in times
of war there's nothing wrong in
possessing money
the problem is when money possesses you
need motivation watch top 10 with
believe nation
what's that belief nation it's Evan this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine and help you
believe in your Michael Jordan level
talent so let's get your motivation to
attend and get you believing in you grab
a snack and join today's lessons from a
man who went from being an electrical
engineer at hewlett-packard to leaving
all of that behind to become a monk and
teach people how to live consciously and
be happy he's gonna go Paul DAWs and
here's my take on his top 10 success vol
4
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one follow the change I believe that the
seven greatest I would say the seven
words which are the greatest enemy of
growth and progress in any field
including what I'm doing a are we have
always done it this way
Nokia thought we've always done it this
way they are out you know blockbuster
thought they've always done it this way
Netflix threw them out if I as a monk
thought that IV have always done it this
way the monks in the past have always
spoken this way they've always been this
way
well I would be out as well my mind not
wanting to be out was not because I
wanted to be the center my not wanting
to be out was so that I can I'll reach
out to people and help make a difference
in their lives so obviously I had to
change with times obviously I had to
change my job then obviously I had to
bring in a bunch of you have a bit of
humor in there obviously I would have to
speak lines which will resonate with
people the it's like I hate using our
but it's like playing old wine in a new
bottle right principles never change
values never change knowledge and wisdom
doesn't change but how you bring it to
people that certainly can change and I
believe that's what's resonated with
people it's not that I'm saying anything
new is the same wisdom the same
knowledge many people are speaking it
but just the way you package it so Nokia
failed in packaging themselves rightly
coming on into digital photography
blockbuster denied when Netflix of
Netflix approached them they're out and
if I think I don't change I don't keep
up with the times
well I'm outdated if you're not updated
you are outdated whether it's
spirituality or the industry out there
it doesn't matter whatever to live in I
think when we talk about being in the
present we don't have to start getting
into the present when the pressure is
high we need to start practicing being
in the present when the
as low as a very nice quote that I read
once in one of the barracks of the
Indian Army which said when you sweat a
lot in times of peace you be less in
times of war
IPL for instance cricket now when the
match is on the world tournaments on the
the competition stuff is you right there
and under the spot which means the
pressure is high and you need to be
focused you need to be present you can
only do it effectively when you learn to
be present in the smaller things of life
I often tell people that when we talk
about being present one thing that we
should start practicing is start being
physically present like I give the
example I have a glass of juice here you
know when I'm sipping this mango juice
why do I need to watch television why do
I have to keep checking messages on my
phone what I'm doing by looking at the
television while looking at the phone is
being distracted from drinking the juice
so I'm drinking the juice let me just
drink the juice what's happening is I'm
being present physically present now
it's not so much about just being
drinking the juice but about cultivating
the attitude behind drinking the juice
of being present and what I'm doing I
also tell people beyond being physically
present we need to also be emotionally
present very often you see people today
are talking to each other chatting with
each other they're looking around here
and there the scrolling on their phones
they're looking at their messages
descending whatsapp messages what
they're doing is they're completely
getting distracted and not learning to
live in the now being emotionally
present means when I'm talking to you
for instance I am with you I'm not
looking at this plant behind me I'm not
looking at the camera here I'm not
looking at the cup of juice I am looking
at you I'm soaking in every single word
as you speak but it's not just about
speaking it's about cultivating the
attitude
of being present rule number three
increase the standard of your life
whether you drive a fox wagon or you
drive a Bentley the road remains the
same isn't it whether you speak on a
Samsung or you speak on an iPhone X
whoever you're calling remains the same
whether you're flying economy or you're
flying business the destination area
heading remains the same isn't it
whether you're wearing a simple fast
track all you wear an Omega or a Rolex
the time remains it's quite amazing how
we work ourselves up so much with
increasing the standard of living that
we forget to increase the standard of
our life and which is why wherever I
travel I make an appeal to people
there's nothing wrong with an Omega is
nothing wrong with a Bentley god bless
you with that anyway habit drive at no
problem but it's trying to enhance and
increase and improvise a standard of
your living please please do not
compromise with the standard of your
life it's not the standard of your
living that makes you happy it's a
standard of your life that makes you
happy and very often we forget to give
our attention to those things that can
truly make us
[Music]
which is why I always say things that
I'm talking about they have utility
value right not happiness value travel
business rather first-class travel no
problem drive apparently no problem but
in doing so never ever compromise on
those principles that also improve the
standard of your life and therefore I
always say some people are so poor so
poor so absolutely for that all they
have is money that's all that's all I
consider that life of poverty stricken
life if all you have is money you're the
poorest person because there's more to
life than money and there's way more to
life than what money can buy and
therefore a many times say if you want
to truly know how rich you are drop it
here and see how many hands come forth
to wipe that deal ladies and gentlemen a
happiness a happiness and I increased
and of life is not in things it's in
people it's relationships it's
meaningful heartfelt deep bondings of
love that bring fulfillment to the heart
it was meaningful exchanges of love that
we share with each other and
relationships that brings true joy to
the heart and isn't it the greatest
irony it's something that brings in the
greatest fulfillment be very
conveniently neglect
in just running after increasing and
enhancing a standard of living rule
number four fine balance the pencil
maker tool the pencil that you know what
is truly important is what lies within
you so as externally we have our work
certainly we have our personality but
internally as a person we have to also
develop so pencil is about finding the
balance between the external and the
internal the external is the casing the
internal is the lead lead that makes an
impact so while we lead a life of
valuables externally we must also
prioritize the values internally while
we lead a life of personality externally
we also need to prioritize being a good
person internally while we live a life
of charisma externally we also need to
live a life of character internally so
the balance between the external and the
internal is the balance of the lead in
the pencil and the casing yeah
rule number five have hope I think this
this one aspect that we all need to
accept and come to terms with in life
there's going to be things that are
beyond our control let's not fight this
back and let's not come into the mode of
controller ship thinking that
everything's in my hands that thinking
that everything's in my hands can
disappoint us for a straight us when
things don't go our way so I think
that's one aspect that I talked about is
up to terms with it that there's going
to be things that don't don't go my way
and everything doesn't go by my watch
life has its watch higher powers have
their watch and things will come to us
also you know this this bulbs right up
here you know they're lighting up the
whole studio of every shooting it's
quite amazing
this bulbs giving their light but
there's many bulbs in the storeroom who
are waiting there to come in the studio
and give their light so that the
shooting can happen when will that bulb
in the studio ever get a chance to come
up here now the beauty of life is that
the bulb up here doesn't last forever
no bulbous lasted forever and no bulb
will last forever
no speaker has lasted for him no speaker
will last forever no actor has lasted
forever in terms of their fame no actor
will last forever no athlete no sports
person has lasted forever and no sports
person will last forever just like this
bulb everyone has their time
everyone has their day and that day
doesn't last for ever so which basically
means the bulb here won't be there one
day and the bulb in the storeroom is
going to get its chance to come to this
lampshade one day to light up the studio
you know what the question in the mind
of that little bulb bear is I agree sir
all this philosophy understood sounds
good all this gone yes sounds great but
I think the parameter the principle be
the value the epoch that actually helps
us continue with perseverance and
patience is hope hope is that one
element that can keep us going the worst
thing to happen in life is to lose hope
and be hopeless so if you're sitting
there waiting for our turn to come up
against hope one day I will also have my
time and my place when how we do not
know because these are factors that are
completely beyond our control rule
number six choose greatness so his
question is how does love or destiny
what role does it play in victory
or success right is it all hard work is
it all destiny what is it now in my
humble opinion destiny is the situations
that come to you which are beyond your
country for example you didn't choose
your parents within your future you were
this time that was destined you are born
as an evil a Mary Bob premium are made
out are behind sir have you ever thought
like that never did you ever choose your
looks
it's a novel you choose no one looks as
good as your facebook profile picture
and no one looks as obvious there are
other our pitch of Nova no one looks
like right so situations situations are
destiny you didn't choose them they came
to you if someone comes and insults me I
didn't choose it it came to me that
situation is this time but my response
to the situation is my choice the
response is not destiny what I choose is
my choice and when I choose it that
decides my future destiny this is why
they say man is the maker of this
destiny not situations situations will
remain what they are but how you
responded to those situations is
completely and entirely your choice you
have that situation which is the style
now you have a choice to a heart to
cultivate that attitude that attitude is
not destiny that attitude is a choice
and when you choose that attitude
hopefully victory will come to you right
away even if it doesn't come to you
right away we have sown the seed that we
may back the seed that a soul will
certainly rectify now Aeneas down the
line 20 years down the line or later
this is why persistence sticking it out
is so much essential rule number seven
prioritize mindfulness the word
mindfulness is a big thing in the world
today mm-hmm I was in San Francisco and
I was invited to speak at Salesforce
okay and Marc Benioff what are the
things he's done at st. horses is
prioritized mindfulness for every single
employee every single floor of their
headquarters in Salesforce has a
mindfulness zone people can go there
practice mindfulness in fact every year
they have this conference called
Dreamforce in the month of November or
two hundred thousand American top-notch
professionals come for the conference
and in that four to five days conference
the last days of mindfulness day where
they invite people who can speak to
their to these professionals so that
they can learn the art of internally
connecting stabilizing their minds
because even Marc Benioff realized when
people are together the output is much
greater then when they are just
distracted and lost you know so the
paycheck is never an issue but if you
cut corners the organization never grow
so I think he's even in terms of
profitability and organizational growth
spirituality does make a difference
because it gives a person good character
integrity a certain values where the
person contributes the most well number
eight be the best version of yourself
when I talk about self-confidence I
talked about trying to be the best
version of yourself you know we are
constantly updating our apps
we're constantly updating our operating
systems whether it's an iOS or an
Android yeah
and the updation of the apps or the
operating systems means to bring the
best versions of what exists and
whenever you're updating to a higher
version of yourself you have to be able
to give the best of yourself to it if
you stick to the older version you reach
the plateau and you don't have to work
harder when you update yourself to a
higher version you have to give the best
of yourself in two hundred percent of
your energy there yeah hard work coming
out of the comfort zone which is where
many times I say you are your own
competition actually that's true nobody
is your competition that's true we have
to compete with ourselves every single
moment every single day to get better
than ourselves to get the better
versions of ourselves to get the best
version of ourselves so when I talk
about self confidence I talk about being
the best version of yourself and having
that full confidence that I can crack it
I can get there rule number nine
transform currency to happiness
it's amazing how money can be known by
so many different ways in a temple
church or charity it's called a donation
in a school it's called a fee in a
marriage dowry and in a divorce alimony
when you owe money to someone it's
called a debt when you pay to the
government it's called a tax in a court
it's a fine when you receive it
regularly after retirement it's called a
pension when an employer gives it to a
worker it's called a salary when a
master gives it to a servant it's called
a wage when children receive it it's an
allowance and when you borrow it from a
bank it's called a loan when you offer
it after a good service it's called a
tip when paid to a kidnapper it's called
ransom when illegally received in the
name of a service is called a bribe and
when used to share and to serve others
it's called happiness there's nothing
wrong in possessing money
the problem is when money possesses you
earn more money fulfill your needs
utilize your money to share and serve
others and transform the value of your
money from currency to happiness and
rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is find your
drive a simple small purse and sanskrit
the words which is mu comparative a
cello even a dumb man can speak fun whom
belong higher pay get him even a lame
man can cross the mountain yet pitamaha
one day she guru Dina param it's by the
grace of sri guru and God that one can
do what we are doing and therefore if
you ask me what is my motivation to keep
going I don't even think I am inspiring
millions or crores as you said people
are watching and people are hearing it's
not my knowledge it's the knowledge
coming from God it's the knowledge
coming from my guru and so many other
monks in the monastery from whom I
learned I simply act as a microphone a
microphone simply amplifies the voice of
the speaker so if there's something
that's motivating people it's not me
it's the knowledge and the power of that
grace that is behind me which is unseen
to your eyes you can't see that but
that's the life that I live when you
don't see me on screens I am in a
monastery in a small little room every
morning practicing my spiritual sadhana
every morning connecting to God through
the chanting of the holy names every
morning I sit and listen to the other
monks I am not only speaking I sit there
I hear others you know I learn from them
and I'm tremendously inspired by the
picture that I showed you cheela Prabhu
path his life I'm tremendously inspired
by his example and of course my guru
rather not much
tirelessly keeps on going and serving if
there's anything that motivates me
it's my chanting it's my hearing it's
the company of my guru and other
like-minded monks that's what keeps me
now I've got a really special bonus gift
from Goa on how to go with the flow that
I think you're gonna really enjoy but
before that is some of the three-point
landing questions time to move from just
watching another video to actually
taking action so here we go
question number one what does balance
look like for you number two how can you
prioritize mindfulness in the very next
task that you are doing and number three
how will you maintain the hope that
things will work out
ladies and gentlemen
isn't amazing how many plans we make and
isn't it a reality
not everything goes according to our
plots even in the game of chess we may
come completely prepared with our
strategy to win the game we may even
make our moves thinking that everything
will go according to what we had decided
and planned
the reality however is once we have made
a move we have no control over the moves
that the opponent will make we have no
idea that the opponent has also made his
or her plan whether it's the game of
chess or the game of life not everything
goes according to what we had envisioned
in our lives this is exactly why there's
a great need to go with the flow to not
be rigid about what we had decided to
learn the change our strategy as per the
need of the moment ladies and gentlemen
and just your plants adapt to the
challenges that life throws at you adopt
new strategies to match those of your
opponent to life apply the greatest
virtue of flexibility don't be rigid
let's learn
a very important lesson from the river
Ganga as she emanates from the Himalayan
mountains with her blood to move and
reach her destination
she is not rigid she is extremely
flexible as sometimes mountains through
challenges in the form of rocks on her
path she does not stop she will either
go above them or under them around them
but she keeps moving until she reaches
her destination whatever challenge comes
on your pathway just keep moving
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that that people need
passion and now one drop of my
self-worth depends on your acceptance of
an
if you want to learn more from gora I
highly recommend checking out the video
it made on him on how to deal with
problems and difficulties in your life
the link is right next to me continue to
believe and I'll see you there read
people don't go through they grow to the
difficulties